gigi hadid and zayn malik's split but
there's also the first trailer for the
fantastic B sequel so we're basically
freaking out about both plus Mel B just
added more fuel to the fire of a spy
school reunion and Katy Perry
accidentally flashed her fellow judges
on Idol everybody Denny here now the
internet is going mad for a couple
reasons today but let's start with the
big news of the day Gigi Hadid and Zayn
Malik are over after more than two years
together
Zayn addressed the split head-on in a
statement tweeting Gigi and I had an
incredibly meaningful loving and fun
relationship and I have a huge amount of
respect and adoration for Gigi as a
woman and a friend hold right there the
dreaded f-word
we don't need this people can exes ever
really be friends can Gigi and Zayn be
friends because fans were quick to point
out li unfollowed his friend Gigi and
her mom Yolanda on Instagram so let me
know while I read the rest of the
statement alright he goes on to say Gigi
has an incredible soul and writes I'm
grateful to all of our fans for
respecting this difficult decision and
our privacy at this time we wish this
news could have come from us first we
love you all Gigi also posted her own
note following the breakup and told fans
I'm forever grateful for the love time
and life lessons at Z and I shared I
want nothing but the best for him and
will continue to support him as a friend
that I have immense respect and love for
as for the future
whatever's meant to be will always be
okay so I might have answered my own
question from before the break-up does
sound pretty amicable to me but what
went wrong
well one report cites it was Gigi and
Zane's busy schedules that call to
strain in the relationship
well don't worry guys hair grows color
changes but I bet Zayn is regretting
that tattoo of Gigi's eyes alright but
we got to move on because we need to
talk about the fantastic beats equal
Warner Brothers dropped the first
trailer for a fantastic beast that
crimes of Grindelwald and it features a
return to Hogwarts young Dumbledore it's
basically jam-packed with Wizarding
World nostalgia
[Music]
I can't move against wrinkled fault it
has to be you I mean come on you even
have to be a Harry Potter fan and know
how dope that looks still the Potter
heads are the emotional about this at
muggle struggled to tweeted me watching
the hashtag fantastic beast trailer with
a gif of Hermione and Ron wiping a tear
at Alicia underscore Malfoy wrote is it
okay that I'm sitting here with the
drawn scar on my forehead and a wand in
my hand live your truth Alicia live your
truth but you know what not everyone was
on board with some of the choices in
this like young Dumbledore's lack of
Wizarding fashion or Johnny Depp's face
at Kim Renfro tweeted this screenshot of
him the stuff of nightmares in more than
one way well we can rest easy knowing
that young Dumbledore is in the hands of
Jude Law who told you back in January
the lengths he went to fill those wizard
shoes you've wrapped you guys are
finished filming what can you tell us
about it playing Dumbledore I mean how
did you take on that man so
do you know what I did I I sat in a room
for an afternoon with JK rowling and I
listened to her extraordinary words of
wisdom and she was kind enough to share
with me the whole back story and her
future hopes for this young that
character of Dumbledore and really that
set me on the path I just did what the
writers said everyone's very excited to
see you and Johnny Depp just go
toe-to-toe in that film yeah the
Chauhan's ready fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald arrives in
theatres November 16
alright thankfully you want the wait as
long for the new season of America's Got
Talent
our favorite show returns to NBC on may
29th and ET was at the official kickoff
party with Mel B what the Spice Girls
yeah are these days you kind of like
drop the the hint that potentially be
performing at the Royal Wedding you
tried you craved like a massive fire
stir well no what's the update on them
we signed to Simon full of the original
Spice Girls manager we signed to him a
few months ago okay you were a tiny baby
with when we went on tour and angel kind
of missed out on that my ten-year-old my
six-year-old is like are you really a
Spice Girl is that really you because
I've got some pictures up of me holding
you in the recording studio my sisters
came in rolling are you gonna get a
chance to do it again at their wedding
we we will be doing stuff this year will
better oh yeah there's Scary Spice
playing it coy but fingers crossed the
Spice Girls slam it to the left shake it
to the right a Prince Harry and Megan
Markel's mate nuptials meanwhile the new
American Idol went head-to-head against
the voice last night and I'll tell you
what Katy Perry and the folks at Idol
try to earn those ratings
Katy's wardrobe malfunction made it onto
Monday's episode take a look
[Music]
yep the Idol judge revealed a little too
much during one of the LA auditions but
she was also brought to tears after
hearing the backstory of 25 year old
David Francisco who was hit by a car and
paralyzed from the waist down I've lost
my voice but like I'm just watching her
and like over at The Voice Kelly
Clarkson also got choked up after 33
year old Stephanie skipper saying
Kelly's ballad piece by piece
[Music]
[Applause]
I bet you on me that you didn't want and
this is embarrassing I'm crying I'm so
mad I can turn the fact that you picked
that song it's cool clearly was an
emotional night for bolt ladies of pop
but who came out on top
seems Kelly is tugging at the
heartstrings of America because the
voice beat out American Idol with eleven
point seven million viewers compared to
idols eight point four million I want to
know which show you guys are watching
let me know while I go hydrate because
that was a lot of news to cover today
thanks as always for watching and we'll
be back tomorrow with more daily Teddy
where's my wand oh I've gotta get out of
here
[Music]